♪
>>> A SIX-YEAR CBS NEWS
INVESTIGATION FINDS POTENTIAL
DANGERS FROM YOUR VEHICLE SEAT
BACKS AND A POSSIBLY OUTDATED
GOVERNMENT SAFETY STANDARD.
WE FOUND THAT VEHICLE FRONT
SEATS CAN COLLAPSE IN REAR END
COLLISIONS LAUNCHING OCCUPANTS
IN THE BACK SEAT WITH DANGEROUS
OR EVEN DEADLY CONSEQUENCES.
CBS NEWS IDENTIFIED MORE THAN
100 PEOPLE WHO WERE SEVERELY
INJURED OR KILLED IN ALLEGED
SEAT BACK FAILURES IN THE PAST
30 YEARS.
AS KRIS VAN CLEAVE REPORTS MOST
OF THOSE ARE CHILDREN.
>> MY WORST NIGHTMARE.
>> Reporter: ON THE WAY HOME
FROM CELEBRATING THEIR SON
TAYLOR'S 4th BIRTHDAY AND JASON
AND KAT HARTWELL'S SEAT,
STRIKING TAYLOR CAUSING A SEVERE
TRAUMA TIC BRAIN INJURY.
THAT WAS FOUR YEARS AGO.
>> IT'S BEEN A BATTLE, SOME GOOD
DAYS AND BAD DAYS.
>> Reporter: HIS PARENTS HARD OF
HEARING WANT TO WARN OTHER
PARENTS.
>> I KNOW, I KNOW.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE DOING TO HELP
PEOPLE OUT THERE.
>> Reporter: OUR CBS NEWS
INVESTIGATION OBTAINED CRASH
TESTS FROM MULTIPLE AUTOMAKERS
SHOWING WHEN CARS ARE HIT FROM
BEHIND THE FRONT SEATS CAN BREAK
AND FALL BACKWARDS, POTENTIALLY
LAUNCHING THE FRONT SEAT
OCCUPANT IN THE REAR OF THE
VEHICLE.
EXPERTS BLAME THE PROBLEM ON AN
OUTDATED FEDERAL SEAT STANDARD
UNCHANGED SINCE THE LATE 1960s.
A STANDARD WE FOUND EVEN THIS
BANQUET CHAIR PASSED.
BUT THE HARTWELLS' ATTORNEY
JOSHUA LEWIS SAID THERE'S EVEN
MORE.
>> THERE'S A BAR MECHANISM IN
THE SEAT IF THAT BENDS THE SEAT
CAN FALL BACKWARDS?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> Reporter: A REPORT IN THE
HARTWELLS' ACCIDENT SAID IN
ORDER FOR IT TO FAIL, THE DRIVER
SEAT HAD TO COLLAPSE REAR WARD.
THE ONLY CAUSE, THE BENDING AND
DISTORTING OF THE CONNECTOR ROD.
IN A DEPOSITION, A SPECIALIST
TESTIFIED HE'S SEEN THAT FILL
BUT ATTORNEY LEWIS HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO OBTAIN THOSE RESULTS.
>> HONDA WON'T GIVE IT TO US.
>> THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE
THE TESTS?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Reporter: AND THE HARTWELLS
ALLEGE A YEAR BEFORE THEIR
ACCIDENT HONDA INSTALLED A
SHIELD IN A LATER MODEL FIX.
THAT SHIELD COULD PREVENT THAT
ROD FROM BENDING.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE FOR WHAT
THE MODIFICATION TO THE SEAT
COSTS?
>> AS CAN BE GLEANED FROM A
PUBLIC RECORD, A FIX MAY LOST
MORE THAN A DOLLAR BUT LESS THAN
TEN DOLLARS.
>> Reporter: IN 2015, HONDA WAS
FINED 70 MILLIONS FOR FAILING TO
REPORT DEATHS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
A YEAR LATER PROMPTED BY OUR
INVESTIGATION, SENATORS ED
MARKEY AND RICHth BLUMENTHAL
SEND HONDAMAKERS A LIST OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT SAFETY.
>> WITHOUT CBS, THIS IS JUST ONE
OTHER SAFETY ISSUE THAT MIGHT
HAVE STAYED UNDER THE RUG.
>> Reporter: IN ITS RESPONSE,
HONDA DID NOT SPECIFICALLY
ANSWER ANY OF THE QUESTIONS
SAYING ONLY 2% OF THE PRODUCT
LIABILITY CLAIMS IN PAST TEN
YEARS INCLUDED ALLEGATIONS OF
SEAT BACK FAILURES.
>> THIS SHOULD BE STANDARD.
>> Reporter: THE CENTERS FOR
AUTO SAFETY JASON LEVINE IS
PUSHING TO MAKE IT SAFER.
>> IF IT'S PREVENTIBLE OF
CTASTROPHIC INJURIES AND DEATHS
WHY WOULDN'T WE ALL BE WORKING
HARD TO MAKE IT GO AWAY.
>> Reporter: IN A STATEMENT,
HONDA SAYS IT'S SAFE AND IT
EXCEEDS FEDERAL SAFETY
STANDARDS.
AUTOMAKER SAYS THE UNFORTUNATE
LEHRY TO TAYLOR HARTWELL DID NOT
OCCUR IN THE MANNER CLAIMED BY
THEIR LAWYERS.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE
TALKING TO US?
>> FIX THE ISSUES.
I JUST WANT TO LIVE A HAPPY
NORMAL LIFE.
BE ABLE TO RUN, DO EVERYTHING A
LITTLE BOY CAN.
I THINK ABOUT IT, OF COURSE, IT
HURTS.
IT'S DEEP, NEVER GET OVER THIS.
>> Reporter: WHILE OUR STORY
FOCUSED ON A HONDA VEHICLE,
THOSE RECLINING RODS ARE IN MANY
TYPES OF CARS ON U.S. ROADS.
SAFETY REGULATORS INSIST THE
SAFEST PLACE FOR KIDS IS STILL
IN THE BACK SEAT OF CARS.
SENATOR ED MARKEY SAYS HE PLANS
TO REINTRODUCE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THAT SEAT BACK
STRENGTH STANDARD TO FINALLY
CHANGE.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING," KRIS VAN
CLEAVE, WASHINGTON.
>> KRIS, THANK YOU, WHE